hey guys how's it going I haven't done
an unboxing up here in my office in
quite some time but today I thought we
would because I've got something pretty
exciting and I've actually already
unboxed this at e3 it is the new Xbox s
real sleek real slim when you have an
Amazon addiction and your recycling bin
is very tiny problem solved all right
baby let's open you up to terabytes 4k
Ultra HD to be honest I i watch most
movies and things on my phone in super
low res I really should start having a
better viewing experience for movies and
TV and stuff like that but not only
carry my items the fall
shall we test the durability
what have we got in here looks a little
stand that looks like something new not
like I saw that in my e3 unboxing I like
that so I think I might stand it up or I
might not
I'm not sure how much they give us some
batteries HDMI the most exciting thing
about this is it especially for me and
probably a lot of you guys is sometimes
I do tend to travel with my xbox and
carrying around that massive power brick
was always so annoying and always added
extra room that I would need to carry my
bag the power is now integrated into the
Xbox so thank you get into this body
shall we look at you looking so good
real thin you've been working out not
that looks quite nice to the stand
there's these little clips
one of the things you really can't tell
is how much smaller this is in size
compared to the previous Xbox look this
beefy boy it's a pretty significant size
difference come on come on turn your
Xbox song if you notice here I have my
name I always gonna confuse when my
sister would bring yours over all of my
items have my name on it even like my
HDMI cables I'm ridiculous
USB port they finally put what in the
front like it used to drive me crazy I
have to go around the side or on the
back we're good to go
like sick guys this is the Xbox one test
I wanted to show you guys the size
comparison and sort of a little bit of
the differences but if you want more
information I'll put a link in the
description where you guys can get that
and you can get yourself the new Xbox
one s I'm gonna go set this up now
so let's go set a little mood lighting
while my dog barks his head off
downstairs here's a nice green for her
of her Microsoft Xbox oh I think I'm
just gonna stop this video and I'm gonna
clean this and make it look nice and
then I'll go start it up because I gotta
do some serious chord reorganization
here here's the sad reality I have so
many courts back here that I'm not even
sure if this looks any better I mean to
me I think it does
I just I'm a chord hoarder but I need
all the chords I'm hoping that I put
everything back together correctly I'm
not sure cuz I unplugged everything so
let's power you on okay things are
happening things are happening it's
really great angle one these chords
drive me crazy
looks like it's finally ready it's
really not going to be much to really
show you but even here we're here no I
don't want opt it again controller is
updated well that's it it's officially
up it's officially running I think the
first game that I'm gonna be playing on
it is like a Star Wars all right guys
that's it I'll see you guys later
happy tech Tuesday it's actually Tuesday
and happy Xbox 1s launch day so like is
dumped into me nope I don't this look
like when I gets all of it